it should be no surprise
that every community should have a right
to a clean environment
yet some are sacrifice zones
sacrifice zones communities living on
the front lines of pollution and
environmental hazards but the good news
is that we have a unique opportunity to
address legacy pollution as we together
build an equitable and just climate
future
now this is a story about communities in
crisis mostly these are communities of
black and brown and indigenous peoples
it's often a story of low-income
communities but race
is the decisive factor now studies show
that an average middle-income black
family with an 87
500 income is likely to live with more
pollution than a white family making
twenty two thousand five hundred dollars
a year
now my organization we act for
environmental justice works within a
movement of hundreds of environmental
justice groups here and abroad to
address the disproportionate impact of
pollution borne by our communities
so i'm talking about environmental
justice which is a civil rights and
human rights analysis of environmental
decision making with a focus
on the permitting the permitting process
that gives polluters permission
to pollute within a regulatory standard
for air water and soil now these permits
they're an allowance that sacrifices the
health of community residents the
cumulative effect of multiple facilities
cited in a community that emit high
levels of pollution in close proximity
to where people live
that contributes to glaring health
disparities
now harvard university studies among
black americans living in areas like
harlem and the south bronx
those are communities which do not meet
clean air standards is set by the
environmental protection agency and
those studies have found
that black americans have died of covit
19 at higher rates than others due to
living in air polluted communities
now that's not a surprise since the
majority of people who live in areas
that do not meet clean air standards are
latinos and black americans and that's
the case in an area called cancer alley
now there's a song sung by the late
night king cole called unforgettable
and that is what cancer alley is it is
unforgettable
it's in the worst possible way
it's a 75-mile
corridor between new orleans and baton
rouge it's a continuum
of petrochemical and plastics
manufacturing facilities on acres of
former plantations
now these facilities have created an
intergenerational history of death from
cancer with some communities
suffering cancer rates higher than the
national rate
now communities experience environmental
hazards and pollution exposure in
diverse ways in urban areas mobile
sources contaminated sites they're
really the challenge and local
governments generally manage the
infrastructure of pollution
but in smaller cities in rural areas
industrial and oil refineries landfills
and incinerators they're usually the
problem and in places like texas and
california there may be no zoning laws
that separate industrial facilities from
residential backyards
so environmental racism and injustice
results from a complex legacy of housing
segregation land use and zoning
discrimination and from unequal
enforcement and policies
now decades ago
such as redlining denied home loans to
people of color and to certain
communities and this government policy
reinforced racial segregation in cities
and diverted investments
away from those communities creating
large disparities in home ownership as
well as urban heat environments a few
trees and no open space so today
we're still living out the legacy of
those racist policies
now i first began organizing around
these issues as an elected democratic
district leader in my west harlem
neighborhood in 1988 i co-founded
west harlem environmental action known
as we act for environmental justice and
you know we began organizing educating
our neighbors to understand the impact
of the disproportionate sighting and
permitting of polluting facilities in
our communities
we started out by
pressing new york city to
fix the north river sewage treatment
plant in the hudson river that was
ruining our quality of life by emitting
toxic fumes
and we began to ask ourselves a number
of questions how could we transform the
new york city diesel bus
fleet to clean fuel buses since we
housed over 740
of the city diesel bus fleet in uptown
depots
how could we have a waterfront park
along the beautiful hudson river instead
of a parking lot
and how could we get environmental
justice
on the agenda of new york city the state
and the federal government to invest in
sustainability in our communities
i know that it only takes one person to
reimagine what's possible and some
policy change takes decades it took us
18 years to transform the new york city
diesel bus fleet to hybrids however it
took only a few months to ensure that
all new york schools
are tested for lead in drinking water
i know that so much is possible when we
have the right political moment but to
capitalize we must mobilize a critical
mass of people to create real change and
to monitor that our policies are
implemented in the way that was intended
and environmental justice groups have
done just that
in a number of ways so we've created
working groups and campaigns amongst
people who have a real stake in the
outcome those most affected by harm or
new policies and we engage them in
environmental decision making those are
the people
who have the lived experience who can
best advise on climate adaptation and
resilience planning now if their
perspectives have been known and
integrated into the interagency
emergency response planning in new
orleans for hurricane katrina
then thousands of families would not
have been stranded on their roofs
waiting for rescue or sleeping in a
sports stadium because the city would
have already known that lower income
families living in a flood zone did not
have a car to evacuate the city or a
credit card to access a hotel room
another tactic we engage is we engage
community and educational workshops that
help them better articulate the data
testify at hearings train residents to
become citizen scientists who collect
their own air and water quality data to
influence policy makers and elected
officials and those officials should
resource every community to develop a
climate action plan
that addresses neighborhood level
response and challenges to extreme
weather events
we've also
developed strong strong policy agendas
at the city state and federal levels
based on community perspectives
experience and the evolving transition
from a fossil fuel economy
and these are tactics that can be
applied within local contexts in any
community
so as we transition
to renewable energy sources we know that
energy insecurity will impact millions
more households as utility bills
increase
and to decarbonize buildings
a pre-investment will be needed to
upgrade residential buildings and front
line communities
before electrification of all buildings
will be achieved
so i challenge you
to create the change we need by
incorporating equity and lived
experience into all public and
government policies
my vision
is to address the legacy of pollution by
targeting frontline communities not for
pollution but to become green zones
green zones where we can incentivize
community shared solar electrification
green businesses good jobs and worker
cooperatives
because today we are at an inflection
point with an opportunity to achieve
that vision
you know the pride administration
has committed to centering environmental
justice in all government policies
through an executive order that directs
at least 40
of the benefits from federal investments
in clean energy to go to disadvantaged
communities so there is an opportunity
to implement a transformative and
accountable process for the fair and
just distribution of benefits of justice
40 to frontline communities of black
brown and indigenous peoples
but we must make certain that the
investments and the benefits reach the
communities intended given the bias and
ambivalence of many state and local
governments
but if done effectively this could be
transformative
and could stop
the cycle of exploitation and extraction
every community every community has the
right to a clean environment and you do
not need
to be an environmental champion or
climate justice leader to embrace that
value
so i call on your humanity
to center the voices and perspectives in
all policies of those most affected by
environmental hazards and climate change
we can create
a legacy of environmental quality and
climate resilience for all we can do
this and we must
thank you